I bloody hate you why don't I ever die
oh hi guys I'd love to say I'm happy
right now but I'm actually feeling kind
of nervous because I played five nights
at Freddy's 2 not very long ago and hey
presto my boots are Freddy's 3 came out
and you're all like hey the third ones
are you gonna play it now and I'm like
oh no I can't get out of this so here we
go let's play five nights at Freddy's 3
oh god it's so loud in my ears I'm in
the dark as well of this light that's
blinding me some of you guys told me to
look at the game theorist and I did it's
actually really interesting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we may have overdone an event some of
this equipment is barely functional I
wasn't joking about the fire the real
the most important thing you want to
watch for is the ventilation look this
place will give me the smokes man and if
you want that ventilation co-op wide and
you'll dirt the atom crazy stuff man
come on listen if it gets all rank Oh
what's this oh oh wait I can see in
vents now to seal event double-click the
vent town button oh oh wow
that is pretty cool I am gonna suck at
this it's way too many cameras here and
I'm already confused hey I don't have a
flashlight you know I mean battery
that's that's the one okay what did I
just do that
why does I'll just click why do I just
click play audio oh this doesn't make
any sense to me by the way I haven't
watched anyone else to play this game so
this is literally me playing five nights
at Freddy's 3 for my first ever time are
you proud of me I don't understand what
I'm supposed to do
I hate that thing why is it there I
don't I don't know what I'm supposed to
do okay it is the next night I didn't do
anything let's celebrate
I'm not go back the way ever again
because why would you because he was
saying that I should be on fire stop oh
okay okay then right so it looks like
we're doing this again
I remember that should we go straight
down let's go straight down see what we
can find
hey mr. purple bear so am i Freddy so
yeah as I was saying the game theorist
he said that this was the secret into
unraveling the story which is that there
was a guy he thinks it might be the
phoned I'm not too sure um era
that's supposed to be the fun guy
apparently trying to kill you and the
fun kids and stuff the kids in suits
yeah that's it oh there you are
what send the audio what do we do
[Music]
[Music]
I'm all ready for you
what does the older to maybe he just
told me I'm not listening cuz I'm so
scared this he's not wait I forgot what
camera was in yet again oh my god I
forget this face why am i paying the
audio comes what is this leave it to how
do I steal things but okay let's just
steal this one let's do seal all of them
that makes me feel happy I don't really
know what stealing does I found I'm
really really bad at this on I don't
know what I am supposed to do okay and
this everything is online oh my geez
hate you hate you still I'm still
playing boy what is he what is he what
is he he didn't he wasn't even there in
this stupid oh wait wait wait let me
think about words he wasn't in the game
theorist video I don't understand what
the new boy is well who he is why he is
what is pretty [ __ ] freak me out well
I didn't die that's a good thing right
yeah oh God video error video wherever
you are let's go go go go go
we pink
[Music]
right so why does he go there's only one
I'm great
this is very unlike the other games
because you can always see them
oh listen audio I don't what do you know
what the audio does why I'm guessing
maybe that if I played it freaks them
out somehow and they stay where they are
a little bit kind of like when I had the
flashlight I don't know I'm just hoping
that it works still there listen I'm
gonna say though it's really really bad
the distortion on these cameras it's
it's terrible
hey oh my god Mike get off this get off
this get off this get off this get off
this I saw you I saw you what do I do
I saw you oh my god you're freaking me
out I totally freaking freaking saw you
it's 5 a.m.
please don't kill me what am I supposed
to do what am I supposed to do
it's 5 a.m. can I last till can I last
can I just pay an oil my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god get off I
wish I could just click off the screen
you're on it off to the left and I think
we just automatically look off the
camera thing this is badger X I tell you
ok hi hi hi hi hi hi mmm what do I do
what do I do with you
whoa ever made it past night too I feel
totally freaking out at the same time
okay shall we go left this time oh look
it's a duck or chicken or whatever with
with a cupcake that's my favorite yeah
let's get down follow me yes I will
follow you I shall do whatever you tell
me to because your purple and everyone
knows that purple things are friendly
yeah it's as really freaky cuz normally
I've at least heard of what the other
games are like follow me oh look it's me
it's the previous me I'm all the foreign
bits yay
I bet the exact same thing is gonna
happen now and I'm not gonna jump
because I'm expecting see I only jumped
a new tiny bit I really don't like this
game can I stop playing now please
and
[Music]
[Applause]
look at my manly breathing could be
creeping creeping I still have no idea
how I'm doing by the way I know I should
really listen to the guy but I can't
because I'm too busy doing all of this
and freaking out and stuff though I can
listen to what he's saying and also
these cameras are really loud so it's
just hard to focus
what does strange noises strange things
are happening biggie
dude shy that wait no no I should have
press reboot all okay just Hey Oh God um
please bugger off yeah that's gonna work
I hate you why don't I ever die dying
I don't want straight up easily I think
that it's good enough for tonight
you can tell I'm freaking out so I'm
gonna leave this be let me know how
badly you want me to play this again and
I will try to pluck up the courage but I
am very happy that I managed to last as
long as I did
so tell me I'm proud I still don't
really understand exactly what I was
doing but I kind of want a place after
watching the game theorist video I do
want to understand the story I do think
there is more behind it than just jump
scares and it interests me if you
haven't seen that video then I'll link
it in the description please give this a
thumbs up or my screams of Terror are
just for nothing so I would really
really appreciate it
have a lovely day or evening